Traduttore: Robert Clarke
Revisore: Michele Gianella
Cosa ci fa un musicista a un TED?
Di solito dovrebbe suonare,
infatti suonerò un poco.
Come prima cosa,
tradirò quello che è il titolo
che ho dato a questo incontro,
a questo speech,
perché mi sembrava
un po' troppo “settoriale”
parlare solamente di musica.
Mi interessava,
visto che il titolo di questo incontro,
in generale, è “tornare a crederci”,
mi interessava parlare
di quello che ho capito nella vita,
di alcuni valori che ho capito
attraverso la musica.
Io faccio un lavoro fortunato
perché riesco a lavorare con l'emotività,
con una parte molto profonda di me
e quindi vorrei riuscire a trasmettere
una serie di cose
che possono essere importanti,
sia per il lavoro creativo,
per chi ha la fortuna di farlo
che, in generale,
anche forse per la vita stessa.
La musica di solito viene vista
come una disciplina molto emotiva,
irrazionale, ispirazionale.
Uno sta alla finestra,
a guardare il tramonto,
con gli uccelli che migrano.
Ecco, quello è l’1% ed è rapidissimo.
Uno deve essere capace,
e nel tempo poi l'ho capito,
ho codificato questo modo di lavorare,
a quell'1% di corrispondere
un 99% di traspirazione,
cioè lavoro, consapevolezza,
ricerca di soluzioni.
Questa è una bella metafora
anche per la vita in generale:
se uno ha un sogno da inseguire,
una visione del mondo,
è importante capire quali siano
i passi concreti che uno può fare
per realizzare quel sogno,
per avere quella visione nella realtà.
Ma soprattutto in un momento
in cui si è, diciamo,
molto concentrati sull'individualismo,
è importante, invece di guardare
verso il basso, verso sé stessi,
guardare verso l'orizzonte,
che è più interessante, sicuramente.
La musica, diciamo,
ha una serie di valori
trasponibili nella vita quotidiana.
Il primo è la trasversalità.
È anche quasi una banalità dire
che la musica è un linguaggio universale.
Io l'ho sperimentato
sulla mia pelle, proprio,
lavorando con musicisti
di nazioni diverse, di continenti diversi.
Ho lavorato con musicisti inglesi,
islandesi, americani,
algerini che parlavano solo l'algerino.
E ho passato due giornate meravigliose
parlando con loro, alla pari.
Questo è un altro tipo di trasversalità.
Oltre che quella geografica,
è interessante la trasversalità, anche,
di ceto, di possibilità
che uno ha avuto nella vita.
Io ho avuto la possibilità di studiare,
quindi ho un certo tipo di linguaggio.
Ma ci sono persone che magari
non hanno avuto questa fortuna.
Ma quando ci si mette a suonare insieme,
si fa musica insieme,
queste differenze spariscono completamente
e si vale tutti allo stesso modo,
si dialoga allo stesso modo.
Sembra una banalità,
ma quando uno le vive sulla propria pelle,
capisce la potenza di queste cose.
Un altro aspetto,
oltre a questa trasversalità
in generale, che è anche generazionale,
cioè con persone anziane e persone giovani
che possono dialogare tranquillamente,
è il fatto che la musica è una specie
di cavallo di troia emotivo, potentissimo.
Se io dovessi descrivere un sentimento
- la nostalgia, dico per dire,
dovrei scrivere molte pagine
con un linguaggio anche abbastanza “alto”,
quindi già ridurrei la capacità
di comunicare questa cosa.
Mentre invece attraverso la musica,
senza nessun tipo di raziocinio,
bypassa la parte razionale.
Se io faccio, se io suono
questa cosa molto semplice.
(Musica)
già subito uno si mette
in uno stato d'animo
che fa pensare a qualcosa di passato,
che manca, ma anche senza razionalizzarlo.
Questo è la nostalgia per la musica.
E ci vogliono 10 secondi per spiegarla,
mentre invece ci vorrebbe
un trattato molto specifico
e non arriverebbe così profondamente,
[con le parole].
Questa cosa mi ha portato anche a pensare
che un altro valore molto importante
è quello di mettersi in discussione.
In qualsiasi progetto che abbia fatto,
in generale, nella musica,
ho visto che è importante
non fossilizzarsi
su un modello acquisito,
in campo musicale ma anche nella vita.
Tutti abbiamo aderito a un modello:
è più semplice, è rassicurante.
Chi è stato fricchettone,
chi è stato dark, i paninari.
Questo tradisce un po' la mia età.
Forse i paninari non tutti li conoscono.
Comunque, insomma, sono modelli
a cui è anche necessario,
- penso in adolescenza, in gioventù -
aderire ad un modello
che ti dica un po' cosa devi fare,
per esistere, per vivere.
Piano piano, uno si dovrebbe
liberare di questa gabbia,
che rassicura da una parte
ma ti imprigiona anche.
Quindi, “mettersi in discussione”
significa ogni volta
cercare qualcosa di diverso,
stare sul limite,
non sulla strada conosciuta.
E qui mi viene in soccorso,
sempre per sintesi,
un mio caro amico, Eugenio Finardi
che ha scritto una canzone,
anni fa molto bella
che si chiama “Non diventare grande mai”.
Io la accenno con la mia voce...
(MUSICA)
“Non diventare grande mai,
non serve a niente sai.
Continua a crescere più che puoi,
ma non fermarti mai.
Perché, vedi, l’avere ragione
non è un dogma statico, una religione.
Ma è seguire la dinamica della Storia
e mettersi sempre in discussione...”
Vedete con quale sintesi,
in dieci secondi,
ha spiegato una cosa che io,
già malamente, ci ho messo più tempo
e probabilmente non sono arrivato
così profondamente come lui.
Tra l'altro, un piccolo inciso:
si può parlare anche d'altro
che non di amore adolescenziale,
nelle canzonette.
Questa negli anni ‘70 era in classifica.
Ecco, questi valori.
Attraverso questo percorso,
io sono riuscito
a codificare questi valori,
che sono, appunto, trasversalità
- e ne abbiamo parlato prima -
e ho fatto parecchi progetti
di questo tipo,
in cui si incrociavano musicisti
di varissima estrazione.
Questa è la Notte della Taranta
con Stewart Copeland, uno dei The Police;
con il bassista degli Area;
Raìs degli Alma Megretta;
un quartetto di percussionisti
che lavorano con Philip Glass;
e una serie di musicisti roots,
come potete vedere, molto popolari
che suonano il tamburello e suonano
la musica tradizionale salentina.
Ecco, in questa babele di linguaggi,
si è riusciti a trovare un Nord,
a portare avanti un progetto
in cui tutti dialogavano
e tutti valevano allo stesso modo.
Quindi trasversalità in senso geografico.
Adesso vediamo...
Questa invece è La Grande Orchestra Rock
che è un altro progetto che ho fatto
per il Primo Maggio a Roma
in cui ho unito, appunto,
sempre per la trasversalità,
molti musicisti di estrazione diversa:
musica classica, jazz,
tutti i più rappresentativi d'Italia.
C’era Boosta dei Subsonica; James Senese;
Stefano Di Battista,
un grandissimo jazzista;
il chitarrista di Vasco Rossi
e il chitarrista di Ligabue.
E tutto questo è successo
con la massima serenità,
proprio perché c'è questa democrazia
insita nella musica.
Un altro valore,
forse ancora più importante, appunto,
di cui ho parlato,
è l'inclusività.
L'inclusività come esatto
contrario di esclusività.
Cioè, di solito c’è
un’etimologia delle parole
che ha dei disvalori in sé.
'Esclusivo' viene visto
come una cosa bella, una cosa figa,
solo per pochi.
In realtà è un disvalore,
un po' come 'privato',
la cui radice è 'privare'.
Invece, uno degli obiettivi
che ho perseguito musicalmente,
ma poi ho capito che è una bella cosa
anche in generale nella vita,
è proprio quello di comunicare le cose
a più persone possibile,
evitando i linguaggi criptici o elitari,
che ti rassicurano,
ti fanno sentire 'particolare',
ma che in realtà mostrano
una grandissima debolezza.
La cosa da fare, invece,
è cercare di comunicare a tutti
delle cose importanti.
Ed è una bugia quella
che il pubblico vuole questo
e al pubblico bisogna dare
delle cose semplici.
Non è vero!
Io ne ho la riprova
nella mia esperienza personale,
cioè con i Deproducers,
sempre per mettermi in difficoltà,
ho messo insieme, da produttore,
altri tre produttori e uno scienziato.
Per un produttore,
che è abituato a entrare
nello studio di registrazione
e dire "Si fa così!",
[perché] sei il capo assoluto,
è un bel allenamento al dialogo
mettersi insieme ad altri tre ego
abbastanza sviluppati come il mio,
ti fa capire quali siano i tuoi confini,
ti fa capire quali siano
le cose meno importanti,
a cui puoi rinunciare,
e ti fa lasciare, a livello creativo,
solo l'idea, la cosa più forte,
più importante,
per metterla insieme alle altre
che saranno altresì importanti.
Quindi, ti fa capire anche
quali sono i confini
e dove finisce la tua libertà
e dove comincia quella degli altri.
Ma ritornando all'inclusività,
la parte testuale,
l'idea è stata quella di far diventare
la Scienza la parte testuale,
per non parlare d'amore ancora,
per l'ennesima volta,
ma per parlare di qualcosa di sostanziale,
di filosofico, anche di quotidiano.
Quindi, il mio obiettivo,
il nostro obiettivo,
è stato quello proprio di far sì
che le persone vedessero
un bel concerto, spero.
Insomma, siamo abbastanza grandi
per essere abbastanza sicuri.
Uno esce, si emoziona,
ma poi ha capito anche
che cos'è il Big Bang,
che cos'è la fotosintesi clorofilliana.
E, per finire, diciamo che...
Vi parlo di una cosa
che non c'entra niente, apparentemente,
che è il messaggio di Arecibo.
Arecibo è un radiotelescopio
in Sud America
da cui è stato mandato, 35 anni fa,
un messaggio verso i confini dello spazio.
Questo messaggio, in realtà,
è poi proprio una specie di grido:
Siamo qui, siamo qui
per cercare vite extraterrestri!
E da 35 anni l'uomo
ha mandato questo messaggio
che è un misto di linguaggio binario,
termini scientifici
ma anche parti molto naive
come il disegnino di un uomo,
il disegnino del DNA.
Perché vi parlo di Arecibo?
Perché, secondo me,
riuscire a comunicare la cultura,
- io ho la fortuna di farlo
attraverso la musica -
ma, in generale, riuscire a comunicare
alle persone a cui teniamo,
ai nostri figli,
è un po' il lascito che diamo
alle generazioni future.
E la cosa più importante che lasciamo
alle generazioni future, secondo me,
è che proprio questo nuovo
modo di collaborare
vuol dire che c'è un modo diverso
di organizzare gli esseri umani,
cioè che questo sistema
non è l'unico sistema possibile.
Grazie.
(Applausi)